I was taking home about twenty thousand  dollars a month for my gym and I was  still sleeping on the floor and here's  why I actually am very security driven I  wanted to make sure that I had a nest  egg which I had pretty much blown in  order to start this business and so  every month all I wanted to do is make  sure that I covered the rent of the  business and then I had no employees at  the time for the first few months and so  I did everything in the business so  everything above the rent was mine to  keep and so every month as it went up my  profit went up but I just filed that all  into savings because I was so worried  about something potentially happening  and ultimately I think it was the right  call because I was able to make bigger  decisions later because of the savings I  was able to have by not getting a place  and spending stuff on Furnishing and all  that kind of jazz